やって
久しぶりだなこんにちははじめ社長です
泣かなく
動画をお休みさせていただきました
[音楽]
矢部裕子となるほどなぁいいしなんかっていうことあるんですけど言えないことのほう
が多くても言えないんですけど
端的にいうとまあなぜ僕が東京に来たか
静岡を出て東京に来て頭がを休んだり結構パタパタしてたんですけどまだバターしてた
ものがついに
終わりましたーーー
疲れをずおっほんとしゃべることがないということがないんだけどもうなんか怖から
このもどかしい感じされることはないやめるべきだと思うよされるべきとか思うんです
けどもう皆さんにしゃべっちゃいけないこととかも多くてけどそれをなかったことにも
できないじゃないですかとしたらまぁなんで休んでたんだよみたいな
うまく説明できないんですけど僕ちょっとバタバタしててちょっと忙しくて本拠に住む
狂っにすぐ愛のこと
なきゃいけないけど忙しくてようやく
[音楽]
ようやくその服がすべきことを縁をややちょっと
ユーチューバーぽいものに戻れる
気がします動画に時間を割くこともなかなかできなかったんですけどか月とか8月とか
もなかなかねようやく終わったんでもう少しちょっとやることがあるんでそれが終わり
次第
やっと東京おさらばして静岡に帰らせていただきます
というわけでえとこれからなんですけどもいつも通りあの普通のメインチャンネルに
戻りますその力を入れてメインチャンネルを作っ
できると思うのでいつも通りし祀る時に動画を見てくれるとありがたいと思っており
ます8月全部と9月全部いたんで2ヶ月ぐらいずっと東京にいたんですけど
[音楽]
なかなかね仕事面ではすごい動画だけだったんですけど動画的に言うとすごいなんかね
外で取りにくかったなって感じです1も美味しい
がすごい汗かいちゃった田中思い同時にこの部屋もうねそっとアレなんですよねが爆発
させようと思ってもなんかしちゃダメな感じですから僕が暴れるに至る場所でもないし
ちょっとやりづらいべ面も結構あったしそもそもモードがスクにしなかなかの不便な
ことが多かったんですけどまぁそれもそれで東京で楽しかったと思っておりますすべき
で多分なんですけどもう1
週刊椎名ゆずに静岡に帰ると思うんでまぁ静岡に帰ってからいつも通り通常運転で
頑張ろうと思っていますのでまたよろしくお願い致しますなかなかねあの何やってんだ
こいつと思われることが多かったと思うんですよツイッターにも全然出てこねーし動画
も上げね詩サブだけはなんか無駄にあげてるし見たいとまず忙しい何分で終わりました
のでそれに手間東京編は終了して東京を売買して
や静岡に帰って後はいつも通り頑張っていければいいなと思っております
そんな感じで検討報告です
[音楽]
今日ねーいつかするのかなと思いますね東京来ることが地域が多いんで一脚また静岡に
帰って投票に来なきゃいけないってことが増えるとまたちょっと大変なのでいつかは
東京に行かなきゃいけないのかなぁとか
東京に住んで見てすごい移動が楽だなっていうのを持ったし本会は2ヶ月しかいなかっ
たんで狩りでバット切ってバットなんかに行っちゃったんですけどちゃんとするのも
考えなきゃいけないのかなぁとか思った2ヶ月間でした
とりあえずほんまに鈴岡帰りたい
そんで遊行したいはほんと遊戯王まで2ヶ月カバーしましたからね僚機いうにか日本と
しませんでしたからねあちょっとしたけどそこは
込めてくださいこと動画便チャンネルは頑張っていこうと思いますそれでは皆もしまだ
お会いし読めばいいん
日本のポケモン図鑑後に式で終わります
me
あっはぁ